salut aujourd'hui on va pas parler
d'argent mais de l'argent avec un grand
à et j'ai clairement repris l'idéal à la
rédaction dans le magazines curieuse qui
était en train de faire une grosse
recherche parce qu'on monte un dossier
dessus alors je vous rassure j'ai volé
que le thème puisque eux vont traiter
des origines de l'argent ils vont parler
des riches de la valeur de l'argent etc
nous on va se consacrer au fait que
l'argent n'existerait pas que l'argent
c'est juste la plus grosse arnaque de
tous les temps qu'en fait peut-être que
tout ça c'est du vent oui j'ai un
nouveau décor c'est pas vraiment un
nouveau décor en fait c'est un fond vert
interactif avec un Loïc on peut on peut
toucher les objets mais ça en vrai c'est
un fond vert regardez preuve je peux te
faire disparaître en post prod alors si
c'était pas un fond vert j'aurais pas pu
faire ça clairement revenons un petit
peu à la Moula on va s'appuyer sur un
documentaire fascinant qui s'appelle
l'argent dette qui a été diffusé en 2008
sur l'histoire du système monétaire et
des banques bien sûr je vais vous mettre
le lien dans la description il a
énormément fait parler de lui à l'époque
un peu dans un autre thème comme le
documentaire hold-up sur le covid et on
va faire un parallèle entre tout ça vous
allez voir ça sent pas bon déjà de
parler de hold-up pour faire une
comparaison moi vous allez voir ça je
vais vous faire une synthèse de ce qui
est dit dans le documentaire c'est assez
dingue vous allez voir c'est agite les
neurones je vous préviens tout de suite
il y a pas besoin de s'y connaître en
économie ou en maths pour comprendre ce
que je vais dire d'autant plus que je ne
n'y connais pas vraiment en économie je
suis pas un spécialiste de l'économie ou
des maths on va aussi voir l'impact que
le document a eu sur le grand public et
les contreberts qui a eu ensuite Loïc
générique de la monarque
[Musique]
alors ce docu l'argent dette c'est un
documentaire qui a été créé par Paul
Grignon un artiste peintre qui est
également vidéaste il a été difficile en
2008 en un an le document a été vu par
plus de 2 millions de spectateurs et
traduire en 14 langues c'est beaucoup
mais ça ramener à 2008 c'est énorme
c'est vraiment la première fois que
quelqu'un expliqué de manière simple et
très ludique comment les banques créent
de l'argent qui n'existent pas ou plutôt
à partir de dettes d'ailleurs on les
retrouve tous les ingrédients de la
méthode de famine dont je vous ai parlé
dans une vidéo précédente sur la mémoire
ces métaphoriques il y a des exemples un
enfant pourrait le comprendre attention
je vais pas vous expliquer le propos du
documentaire dans une optique de
dénoncer quoi que ce soit sur le système
monétaire ou autre ni même de vous
convaincre d'ailleurs que ce docu a
raison c'est pas le but ce jeu en
deuxième partie vous parlez de tous les
propos qui sont venus contredire le
travail de Paul craignant et qui ont eu
forcément moins de visibilité et encore
une fois je m'y connais pas assez pour
dire s'ils ont toujours raison ou pas
donc c'est plus pour vous montrer en
fait les deux parties n'hésitez pas à
faire des recherches sur des sites
fiables pour un peu affiner votre avis
là-dessus donc le docu commence par la
genèse de la banque pour comprendre les
banques il faut donc comprendre les
banquiers Paul Grignon explique tout
d'abord comment est né le métier de
banquier alors gin ce serait des
Orfèvres qui louent un espace de
stockage pour que la population puisse
protéger sonore normal comme ils étaient
orfèvres ils avaient besoin de planquer
des choses donc on va dire qu'ils
avaient forcément un système sécurisé
évidemment quand quelqu'un déposé de
l'argent il leur faisait un reçu sur
lequel était notée la somme qu'ils
avaient déposée dans le coffre mais ça
devenait embêtant d'aller toujours
retirer son or en échange du reçu quand
on avait besoin de liquidité donc au fur
et à mesure la population a trouvé un
système simple changer le nom du reçu
pour la tribuer à quelqu'un d'autre qui
veut dire que ce quelqu'un d'autre
pouvait aller à la place du précédent
propriétaire directement chez leur fait
pour aller chercher l'or en son nom en
gros c'est là qu'est né le fameux petit
papier qui est devenu plus tard un
billet de banque et tout le monde était
ok avec ça c'était plus simple pour tout
le monde a commencé pour les commerçants
d'avoir des reçus plutôt que des sacs de
pièces d'or et on va dire c'est c'est la
base qui fait qu'ensuite est apparu
l'argent qui n'existe pas mais qui
existera après au départ l'orfèvre qu'on
appelle le banquier prend des sous pour
garder l'or parce que c'est sécurisé
mais c'est pas dingue comme revenu il
prend pas un gros pourcentage il prend
pourcentage c'est normal il rend un
service donc ça ça se fait sauf
qu'ensuite leur fait ce serait rendu
compte que personne ne vient chercher
tout son normal en même temps et que ça
n'existe pas un moment où tout le monde
viendrait chercher tout son or en même
temps et comme à côté de ça il y a des
gens qui lui disaient des fois
excuse-moi tu aurais pas 20 pièces d'or
à me prêter il s'est dit il y a
peut-être moyen de faire un business un
peu plus rentable il a commencé à faire
des prêts avec leur des autres déposants
il rendait donc un service un service
space l'orfèvre a donc demandé des
intérêts mais mieux que ça il a ensuite
simplement utilisé les reçus c'est à
dire qu'il ne donnait même pas l'or qui
avait dans le coffre il faisait un reçu
de pièces d'or qui était potentiellement
dans le coffre ça vous paraît compliqué
exemple simple j'ai 100 pièces d'or dans
le coffre de l'orfèvre ils sont à moi on
va dire dans le coffre du banquier c'est
plus simple Loïc il en a zéro il en a 0
parce qu'il dépense trop son or mais il
a besoin en ce moment de pièces d'or il
lui en faut 150 pour à nouveau téléphone
portable voilà pour qu'il a jamais
dehors parce qu'il achète trop de
portable le banquier il va alors prêter
mes 100 pièces d'or à Loïc et va lui
demander 10% de pièces d'or d'intérêt
pour avoir pris le risque de lui donner
mon argent sans me le dire en plus parce
que cette époque là les orfèves c'était
bien caché de dire qu'il se faisait du
pognon dans le dos de leurs clients mais
si vous calculez bien il manque encore
50 pièces d'or pour que Loïc puisse
acheter son téléphone est-ce que
l'orfèvre il avait que mes 100 pièces à
moins dans son coffre alors le banquier
va juste émettre un reçu disant qu'il
prête 150 pièces d'or en tout aloïc et
il y a bien 100 pièces qui existent dans
le coffre les miennes mais pour les 50
qui n'existent pas le banquier compte
sur les remboursements de Loïc pour
qu'elles existent dans le futur le
calcul est très simple une fois que le
hic a remboursé son prêt il reste donc
alors faite 15 pièces dehors les 10%
juste pour lui grâce à mes 100 pièces
d'or et aux 50 pièces d'or qui
n'existaient pas mais qui maintenant
existe d'ailleurs du coup elles sont
acquis les 50 nouvelles pièces d'or
parce que les 100 on sait qu'elles
étaient moins mais les 50 elles sont
acquis ça c'est pas la question il a
donc créé de l'argent grâce à décidé de
Loïc et c'est là que la dette est
devenue le moyen principal de créer de
l'argent on avance dans le documentaire
point de vue de la législation Paul
Grignon explique l'ordre moral considéré
que c'était du vol mais après ils ont
changé d'avis ils ont dit attend déjà
demande des crédits le banquier il prend
le risque de créer de l'argent c'est
normal qu'ils se fasse du blé pour ses
services et puis voilà il s'organise
quoi donc on a légalisé ce qui
paraissait moral c'était de faire de
l'argent avec de l'argent c'est ça qui
est qui est immoral comme ça le premier
abord mais ça permettait une croissance
économique plus on prête de l'argent à
une population plus la population achète
construit crée des richesses créer des
sociétés avec des emplois par exemple et
donc la fortune du pays augmente c'est
ça qu'on appelle le PIB plus on prête de
l'argent plus le PIB du pays s'accroît
mais quand même il fallait pas que le
banquier fasse n'importe quoi donc on a
légiféré en gros plus tard on a légiféré
avec la banque centrale qui est en
quelque sorte un peu la maman des
banques qui dit aux banques privées
combien elles peuvent prêter parce que
oui maintenant les banques ne prêtent
pas seulement l'argent qu'elles ont en
banque elles prennent donc bien aussi
l'argent anticipé à partir des intérêts
des remboursements à et c'est la banque
centrale qui décide de jusqu'à combien
elles peuvent prêter et certaines
banques peuvent prêter jusqu'à 30 fois
la somme qu'elle possède réellement
attention je tiens ce chiffre du
documentaire l'argent est donc créé non
pas à partir de l'argent déposé ni des
bénéfices mais à partir des promesses de
remboursement par les emprunteurs qui
doivent payer des intérêts Paul Grignon
explique que donc la seule chose qui a
une réelle valeur c'est la dette que
vous contractez au moment de votre prêt
c'est que des lignes bancaires qui ont
pas plus de valeur matérielles que le
petit bout de papier de l'époque ou que
le billet de 10 euros qui est dans votre
poche le document que l'argent créé par
le gouvernement représente moins de 5%
de l'argent en circulation 95% de
l'argent a été créé par quelqu'un qui a
créé une reconnaissance de dette à une
banque la seule chose réelle ce sont nos
actifs maison voiture télévision etc qui
seront confisquées si jamais en
rembourse pas donc ce qui est fou c'est
que l'argent est créé à partir de
promesses si je vous promets de vous
payer un plein d'essence la promesse ça
va pas vous donner de l'essence vous
allez pas pouvoir rouler pour autant
mais pour les banques la simple promesse
de prêter de l'argent fait que ça se
transforme en argent véritable en pas
dépensable il y a même des pays où
l'argent physique n'existe plus du tout
il y a une partie là-dessus dans le
dossier de curious du magazine qui va
sortir qui parle de ça c'est stupéfiant
donc la conclusion qu'on peut se faire
dans ce docu à ce moment-là c'est que
s'il y a pas de dette il y a pas
d'argent on dépendrait donc du
renouvellement perpétuel des demandes de
crédit bancaire ça c'est ce que j'avais
cru comprendre moi aussi à titre
personnel citoyen lambda c'est ce qui
s'est passé durant la Grande Dépression
1929 quand la quantité des prêts a chuté
autrement dit la banque ne prête pas
d'argent elle le crée c'est elle crée de
l'argent dette on est sur un système de
croissance exponentielle toujours plus
ça c'est pour que la société fonctionne
il faut créer de plus en plus de
nouvelles dettes pour payer les dettes
précédentes et ça ressemble à filmer
prendre à une pyramide de Ponzi qui
consiste à rémunérer les investissements
de clients essentiellement par les fonds
procurés par les nouveaux entrants j'ai
fait une vidéo sur les permis de Ponzi
je vous la mettrai en description en
temps normal sachant que ce système ne
peut pas être infini un moment donné il
est obligé de s'écrouler c'est-à-dire
qu'à un moment les intérêts seront
impossibles à rembourser ça qui est très
fort dans son documentaire parce que que
ça soulève la question de comment
rembourser des intérêts s'il y a pas
assez d'argent qui circulent si ce n'est
en s'endettant encore plus pour
rembourser ces fameuses intérêts et puis
sur le principe de faire de l'argent
avec de l'argent aujourd'hui faire ça
c'est considéré comme un idéal à
poursuivre il y a pourquoi travailler si
on peut faire bosser son argent pour
soi-même c'est le principe des rentiers
qui ne vivent que sur les intérêts que
leur argent génère on voit en espané de
pub en ce moment de de comment faire
pour gagner de l'argent sans rien faire
juste un investissant la valeur travail
ou mérite ou action ou productivité au
sens réel de qu'est-ce que j'apporte
réellement à la société comme service
comme savoir-faire comme culture enfin
tout ce qui tout ce qu'on peut
quantifier en tout cas dans un quotidien
ben non l'investissement pur c'est
fabriqué de l'argent à base d'argent on
termine par la question comment avoir
une économie durable Paul Grignon offre
une vision économique afin d'avoir une
économie stable qui dépendrait pas de la
dette pour sortir de l'engrenage de
cette dette perpétuelle il y a une
solution à ses yeux optez pour la
croissance zéro ou même pour la
décroissance d'un point de économique
évidemment Grignon ainsi sur ce point
car selon lui la croissance ne peut que
faire s'écrouler l'économie il n'y a pas
d'autres alternatives il dit qu'il
faudrait imaginer de l'argent stable qui
resterait stable qu'est-ce qu'il appelle
l'argent instable et bien l'inflation en
ce moment on le voit pas mal on en parle
beaucoup mais à titre d'exemple je me
souviens que ma mère m'avait dit que
pour son premier emploi elle gagnait 800
francs par mois c'est un salaire correct
et ça fait 120 euros aujourd'hui vous
imaginez pas vivre en France avec 120
euros donc c'est bien que tout a
augmenté c'est ça qu'on appelle l'argent
instable Grignon propose que les banques
ne donnent que l'argent qu'ils ont
apprêté pour préserver l'équilibre et
que les intérêts soient distribués à la
population avec une taxation lourde sur
les bénéfices par exemple mais dans ce
cas quel intérêt aurait les banques
d'être en affaires s'ils peuvent plus
vraiment gagner d'argent avec ça c'est
là qu'il faudrait imaginer des banques
sans but lucratif qui travailleraient au
service de la société elle pourrait
verser des dividendes universel aux
citoyens ou encore prêté sans faire
payer d'intérêt pour créer de l'argent
en permanent il suffirait que les
banques créent de l'argent et de
dépenses
dans l'économie infrastructure durable
comme les routes les chemins de fer les
marchés publics l'appartement de Loïc
c'est toi qui a rajouté ça au texte
et c'est là où il faut comprendre la
nuance cet argent serait plus de
l'argent dette mais de l'argent qui
aurait la valeur des infrastructures
financiers ça redonnerait toujours de la
substance en fait à une ligne monétaire
si cet argent facilite très le commerce
il y aurait pas d'inflation l'inflation
j'insiste dessus c'est lorsque tous les
prix augmentent globalement et pas
seulement quelques biens et ainsi ça
augmenterait également le pouvoir
d'achat il faudrait une réforme complète
et plus qu'une réforme vaudra un nouveau
système et quand on écoute l'explication
de crayon ça semble se tenir Grignon va
même plus loin parce que aujourd'hui
quand il y a une inflation on subit deux
choses l'inflation plus la taxation
puisque la plupart des taxes sont en
pourcentage quand quelque chose augmente
et bien la taxe augmente ne serait-ce
que la TVA en moyenne vous payez 20% de
TVA sur tout ce que vous achetez si par
exemple vous achetez habituellement un
produit qui coûte 10 euros sur ces 10
euros il y a 2 euros de TVA pour l'État
si ce même produit augmente de 10% il
passe à 11 euros et bien du coup il y
aura 2,2 euros de TVA pour l'État dans
la proposition de Grignon c'est soit
l'un soit l'autre soit il y a inflation
il y a taxation et pour lui ce serait à
l'état de gérer l'inflation en mettant
plus ou moins de d'argent en circulation
par exemple en gros il décrit un petit
peu le film Time Out je sais pas si vous
avez pu ce film ou il y a pas d'argent
et tout tout est géré avec du temps en
fait du temps de vie il y a une phrase
dans ce film qui dit je crois pour pour
quelques immortels il faut que beaucoup
meurent et bien là c'est pareil si on ne
fait pas une décroissance ou plus
exactement une croissance zéro pour
préserver l'équilibre on vivra toujours
dans un système monétaire qui tant qu'à
la spéculation des plus riches et
l'endettement permanent des plus pauvres
la conclusion de grignons et de son
documentaire c'est que ludique ce qu'on
appelle nous démocratie liberté c'est un
diktat économique tant qu'on
fonctionnera sur le crédit bancaire ce
sont les banques qui décideront de qui
recevra de l'argent ou pas par exemple
et le film se termine sur des citations
d'anciens présidents morts assassinés
qui aurait dénoncé ce système bancaire
il sous-entend qu'ils ont peut-être été
assassinés pour avoir été dénonciateur
et c'est là où il y a des bizarres dans
son en gros il y a des trucs qui sont
hyper intéressants tout est très
stimulant mais il y a une petite odeur
de il dit pas un peu ce qu'il veut des
fois il fait pas un peu des raccourcis
ils colle pas une mort trop vite en lien
de cause à effet avec quelqu'un qui
aurait dit quelque chose sur le système
bancaire c'est en ça que ça me rappelle
un petit peu hold-up ça répond un peu
trop à notre désir de dire les banques
c'est pas des gentils alors avant de
passer à la deuxième partie
entendons-nous bien c'est sûr que le
principe de de créer de la dette en
permanence est important pour soutenir
en fait la croissance et l'équilibre du
système économique mondial et c'est un
vrai problème c'est dire ça c'est pas
normal du tout que ce soit comme ça
quand tu commences à mettre un peu ton
nez là-dedans dans l'économie mondiale
te dit
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon et puis ça
va tomber à un moment donné ça peut pas
être autrement maintenant encore une
fois je m'y connais pas assez pour pour
moi des bunker ce documentaire et
étriers un petit peu ce qui ce qui est
vrai dedans et les raccourci qui a pris
Grignon et quel est son parti pris qui
passe pour un parti objectif mais c'est
sûr que il faut vraiment pas prendre ce
docu au pied de la lettre même s'il
reste intéressant à regarder ne prenez
jamais ce documentaire comme une source
absolue et pour le coup le film a
suscité énormément de réactions de la
part d'expert le travail de Grignon a
été salué en France par de nombreux
médias mais il a soulevé aussi des
oppositions de personnes qui criait au
complot Paul Grignon a été accusé de
complotisme on l'accuse principalement
de prendre d'énormes raccourcis comme je
vous le disais bon spoiler c'est le cas
à l'époque l'émission arrive sur le
nuage a très rapidement fait une
émission avec des spécialistes de
l'économie qui sont venus contredire
tous les propos anaristes de grignons je
vous mettrai le lien dans la description
si on peut encore le trouver ils ont
notamment critiqué le film de venir
créditer des tests conspirationnistes
tout en étant convaincu que son succès
venait du fait qu'il validait les
préjugés qu'on a sur les banquiers c'est
là où ça me rappelle hold-up parce que
le banquier il a pas une image très
positive il est souvent représenté par
un personnage un peu véreux sans moral
comme monsieur Burns ou sorte de Picsou
c'est un billet de formation tout
simplement Alexandre delegue un
économiste présente sur le plateau
affirme que les mécanismes monétaires
sont présentés de façon incomplète et
que le fait que l'extinction d'une dette
détruise de la monnaie n'est pas
présentée dans le document mais les
invités par contre le répondent pas à
deux questions majeures qui sont est-ce
qu'il faut une croissance exponentielle
c'est une vraie question et bien si vous
regardez l'arrêt sur image vous verrez
que la 65e minute le spécialiste il
lutte complètement la question la thèse
finale effectivement celle de la
décroissance il est
de la croissance zéro enfin mais moi ça
dépasse ça qui m'intéressait c'était
uniquement la rémunération du banquier
c'est un service rendu on peut dire donc
effectivement qu'on rémunère le banquier
pour son 7 pour ce service qu'il fournir
de la dette alors moi à titre personnel
est-ce que je pense qu'il faille une
croissance exponentielle moi je trouve
que la réponse elle est dans la question
en fait d'une manière générale pour tout
il ne faut pas de croissance
exponentielle et tout le système de
notre monde de notre société fonctionne
sur la base de l'exponentielle c'est à
dire que même là sur youtube il faut
toujours plus de vues toujours plus de
clics toujours plus de like toujours
plus d'abonnés et les plateformes en
veulent toujours plus tout ce que vous
regardez autour de vous c'est toujours
plus mais l'être humain un système de
pensée qui est comme ça il veut il veut
accumuler en fait en réalité et dans nos
mécanismes cérébraux le fait de vouloir
plus c'est un moteur qui nous pousse à
avancer c'est ça qui fait qu'on s'en est
sorti nous les êtres humains plutôt que
de se laisser à l'état préhistorique
c'est ce qui nous fait évoluer mais
c'est clairement le revers de la
médaille parce que la seule fin possible
si tu veux faire une croissance
exponentielle avec des ressources
limitées c'est que ça s'écroule ça vous
fait penser à d'autres choses l'écologie
il y a plein d'autres choses bah c'est
normal la deuxième question qui avait
été plutôt éludée dans arrêt sur glace
c'est d'où viennent les intérêts vous
rappelez grignons expose qu'il y a pas
assez d'argent qui circule pour
rembourser les intérêts si ce n'est en
contractant des nouveaux prêts pour les
rembourser et là c'est le chien qui se
mord la queue ça vient d'où à 69 minutes
vous pouvez voir une invité posée
clairement la question et son
interlocuteur il répond clairement pas
allez regardez ça vaut le coup d’œil
alors des réponses à ces questions il y
en a bien sûr dans le numéro de novembre
de mon magazine curieuse donc je vais
pas tout développer ici si vous le savez
pas mon magazine est disponible à partir
de 19,90 en numérique ou à partir de 39
90 dans votre boîte aux lettres partout
dans le monde c'est le prix pour une
année complète ou vous recevez tous les
magazines le nouvel obscient avait
travaillé sur la question pour savoir si
on est des condamné à une dette
perpétuelle avec des économistes qui
avaient dit que la création des
richesses et que la croissance
permettait justement de remettre les
compteurs à 0 alors que tout évoluer
mais que ça permettait justement de
garder un équilibre et de Nouvel Obs
avait également sorti donc un article
qui répondait à Grignan sur le fait que
je cite les gouvernements étaient
complices de leur maître les banquiers
si le gouvernement crée uniquement
l'argent dont il a besoin
notre servitude collective et
perpétuelle envers les banques
l'état n'emprunte pas auprès des banques
à court terme c'est même plutôt l'État
qui prêterait de l'argent alors
attention on s'assied pour comprendre ça
on va parler des obligations en réalité
l'État va pas nécessairement à la banque
faire toc j'ai besoin d'un crade
financement frérot l'État peut émettre
des titres qu'on appelle des obligations
dites-vous que dans la grande vie de la
Bourse il y a les actions et les
obligations et d'autres trucs à côté
mais là on s'en fiche les actions c'est
clairement j'achète une part de cette
société on estime qu'elle votant
aujourd'hui mais on peut spéculer pour
se la racheter cela revendre plus ou
moins cher et cette part cette action en
réalité c'est la capacité de recevoir
une petite partie des bénéfices à la fin
de l'année c'est-à-dire que quand la
société elle fait son bilan de fin
d'année s'il y a du bénef à la fin et
qu'on le redistribue et bien dans la
redistribution on aura ce dont on a le
droit en termes de pourcentage avec son
petit titre ça c'est une action les
obligations c'est différent c'est de la
dette par exemple moi Fabien je lance
une une obligation de 100 euros on va
dire et je dis qui veulent l'acheter
s'il vous plaît achetez-la si vous
derrière votre écran vous dites ben moi
je l'achète vous avez la garantie parce
que je l'ai marqué dessus que jusqu'à
temps que je la rembourse que je la
rachète en fait mon obligation je vous
verserai tant d'argent tous les ans donc
on retrouve un peu le système de
l'action et quand est-ce que j'y mets
fin mais quand je rachète ma propre
obligation c'est aussi bête que ça donc
a priori n'importe qui peut acheter cet
obligation il les obligations d'État
elles se vendent très bien elles sont
très peu performantes en termes de
rémunération mais c'est un placement
relativement sécurisé parce que on dit
qu'un État ne peut pas faire faillite
donc à un moment donné cette obligation
elle vaudra toujours quelque chose en
fait elle sera toujours viable au
remboursement les économistes doivent se
tirer les cheveux et j'essaye de faire
simple éclair donc pour se financer
l'État et mes titres négociables des
obligations qui sont souscrites par des
particuliers par des entreprises par des
assureurs par des institutions la dette
publique elle est financée par leur
épargne et là je vais vous parler de
Jean zin ou janzine je sais pas comment
ça se prononce un altère mondialiste et
aussi philosophe martien qui à la base
est contre le système monétaire il a
déclaré que la principale source
d'erreur de ce film ce serait justement
de réduire le problème de l'argent en se
focalisant sur lui sur l'argent au lieu
de considérer plutôt le système de
production dans tout son ensemble selon
lui il n'y a pas de croissance
exponentielle des dettes qui serait
irremboursable parce que les banques ne
prêtent pas plus que vous ne pouvez
emprunter en comptant les intérêts en
temps normal il insiste aussi sur le
fait que ce ne sont pas les prix avec
intérêts qui créent l'écroulement d'une
économie mais bien la pure spéculation
façon chienne pyramidale qu'on parlait
tout à l'heure selon lui docus créé
encore plus de confusion dans les
esprits non pas parce que tout est faux
mais parce que toute une partie serait
fausse et encore une fois je suis pas là
pour vous dire ce qui est vrai ou ce qui
est faux mais je vous invite vraiment à
regarder les documentaires que je vous
mettrai dans la description afin de vous
fassiez votre propre avis mais pas un
avis d'opinion encore une fois
méfiez-vous de vos propres billets en
particulier du billet de confirmation
chercher des sources fiables et à ceux
qui se disent ben ouais mais Fabien
alors pourquoi tu fais une vidéo
là-dessus nous on attend des vidéos
entiers des doc long terme qui pote qui
te demande deux ans de travail quoi je
vous répondrai à aller voir les chaînes
d'économie par exemple aller voir ceux
qui s'y connaissent vraiment par contre
moi je trouve ça intéressant d'amener
sur ma chaîne ou il y a une certaine
audience suivant les vidéos le sujet de
le poser là et qu'on puisse commencer à
s'y intéresser en fait passons à la
conclusion de tout ça je peux pas
m'empêcher de faire un parallèle je vous
l'ai dit plusieurs fois avec le
documentaire à succès hold-up docu qui
prétend dévoiler la face cachée de
l'épidémie le documentaire remet en
cause les mesures sanitaires prises la
gravité du virus affirme dénoncer la
machination d'une élite corrompue je
vous invite à regarder fakeup quand ça
va sortir mais bien sûr des journaux
comme Le Monde ont très vite démonté les
propos du documentaire en apportant eux
aussi leur part de fait et ou de vérité
autrement dit je crois que lorsqu'un
documentaire fait autant débat et de
plus alors qu'il traite d'un sujet qui
souvent nous dépasse ou dans lequel cas
on n'est pas expert on n'est pas
compétent il est capital et nécessaire
de garder une vigilance sur les
conclusions qu'on peut se faire
faites-vous votre propre avis ou pas
d'avis aussi pourquoi pas et n'oubliez
pas que l'argent fait le fait le bonheur
oui j'ai dit l'argent fait le en fait
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur de tout
le monde au sens strict du terme mais il
peut faire le bonheur des plus démunis
qui n'ont rien ce qui dorment de la rue
ceux qui ont faim l'argent ça doit pas
être une quête en soi mais ça doit être
un moyen possible de gagner une liberté
d'agir une liberté de faire d'être en
tout cas tant qu'il y aura pas un autre
système et que la société sera régie par
le système monétaire merci pour la
qualité de votre écoute parce que si
vous êtes encore là c'est que vraiment
vous êtes un petit peu quand même
accroché au truc prenez soin de vous
rendez-vous lundi prochain à 18h au plus
tard peut-être tu auras une vidéo
vendredi à très bientôt Ciao